[Music]
time for me does not exist as anything
like a line on which you can arrange
things I would say that time ism the
expression is emergent what for me
really exists is myself and you and
thinks the chair I'm sitting on those
are for me all real or at least behind
them there is something which is real
but I don't think there is any time like
a substance like any fluid or anything
like that if you were to take as you are
doing now making a film of me you could
cut that up into stills of the movie and
then you could put them together at a
certain distance apart to make it just
exactly as happens with the movie so
that it runs smoothly and it seems to
make sense and I think time is is an
illusion which emerges really out of the
law that governs the whole universe
which puts things together
I called them now puts things together
in that way to create that impression
that there is an all-powerful thing
moving us forward and this is sort of a
line of timeline or something like that
but I think that's all an illusion
ultimately but you and I are real don't
worry about that what was it that made
you move away from seeing time as being
else we cut upon a line to seeing as
emergent how did you come to realise
that time was an illusion well it it was
a just reading one single sentence by a
great British physicist Paul Dirac so I
was 26 I wanted to become an
astrophysicist I started working on a
PhD in astrophysics and I happened to
read a newspaper article in Germany
where I was studying about the great
Paul Dirac's efforts to unify quantum
gravity mechanics and Einstein's theory
of relativity and he had come to the
conclusion that there might be something
wrong with the most fundamental thing
that Einstein is famous for that there's
no definition of simultaneity the
you may probably heard of the block
universe or space-time in which there's
no given simultaneity you can cut up
space-time in all sorts of different
ways like that and Dirac had found
evidence within the dynamical structure
of Einstein's great theory of gravity
that that might be wrong and he had he
just said one sentence he said this
result inclines me to believe that
four-dimensional symmetry is not a
fundamental feature of the physical
world he said this in in an article in
published an article in 1958 with this
and I read an article in a newspaper
about that and it made me start thinking
about time and I'd never really
seriously thought what is time before
and then I realized we would never have
the idea that time is passing unless we
saw motion unless we were aware of
change so ever since then I've been
convinced that the primary thing is
change or if you like even difference
and that what we are feeling of time and
that it passes all emerges out of
differences out of out of the fact that
we in the first place we experience
change we would never have the idea that
there is something that we call time
passing if we weren't aware of things
changing so what's the difference if we
move to naming it as change rather than
time because it leads you to think about
how the universe by what law might be
governing the universe the way things
how differences arise within the
universe and at the moment I'm very
interested in how structure arises in
the universe we know that near the Big
Bang the universe was was very
homogeneous uniform there were sort of
waves coming backwards and forwards if
you like but it was all very uniform and
here am I talking to you
pretty ordered and still reasonably
competent can talks moderately good
sense how on earth does that come into
existence how how what is governing the
universe that makes that possible and
this huge change from the conditions
near the Big Bang
- now these these are fascinating issues
and for me they all come out of asking
what is time and saying actually time
must be about differences if I had my
progress book that my mother so
conscientiously kept with pictures of me
when I was one and two and you know and
look at me now it's still the same
person more or less but huge differences
and that's that's how you can tell I've
got older and there was a young little
boy and now there's a man in his early
eighties so that's what that's the
evidence that leads people to think this
time but I say let's let's just look at
what really is and say no let's only
construct our theory with what we can be
reasonably confident confident does
exist and does this what is left then of
the Einsteins of space-time continuum it
it emerges the the way I think about it
you could my hands are almost the same
so I can put my 1 my left hand on top of
my right hand like that and then I can
so that's sort of putting it in in
spatial where it is one on top of each
other and then if it's slightly
different I'll put a certain distance
between them now that's not a real thing
that's in my mind to try and make sense
of how how my left hand can be placed
relative to my right and how much
difference there is between them so if I
have lots of hands or lots of movies
stills of a movie I can stack them I
call that horizontal stacking and then
vertical stacking and in in all cases
the real thing is it's my hands but then
I stack them one after another both this
way and that way using only what is the
structure in the hands and out of that I
can construct space-time and this is not
the way people normally think about it
but when you look at it that way things
are different and I say we must
philosophize about these things
differently so that that's the
difference there so in a way time is an
illusion my hands are not an illusion
but saying that they're stacked like
that is is something that I've put into
it to understand the difference between
my left hand and my right hand so how
would you then understand why we feel
like we experience time the temple
nature of reality that is the real the
big problem where does how does
consciousness come into this so I start
off with the great insight that the
geologists had in in the late 18th
century they got very interested in
studying the earth and they discovered
what is called deep time they realized
that if they were to understand that the
structure that the earth has now and by
the way that structure has hardly
changed since they started thinking
about these things that well over 200
years ago they supposed that the earth
was a physical object that had been
changing in accordance with definite
laws of nature over a very long period
and this led them to the idea of deep
time and it's all encoded in you could
see that the rocks and the fossils are
in some sense is you could see them as
records which you could interpret and
say this is how the past unfolded and
there's a wonderful statement
Lamarque who had ideas about evolution
before Darwin they turned out to be
wrong but Lamarck has a wonderful
sentence he said the surface of the
earth is its own historian it always
encoded in the surface of the earth you
look around you here it really is behind
me is is the history of the earth a
geologist can deduce all sorts of things
from that and I call that a time capsule
now I would say that in my mind there's
something like a time capsule like that
that there's lots of memories and
they're all they're all consistent
really in a way
there's a wonderful moment at the end of
the midsummer night's dream when
Hippolyta says no it must be real what
these lovers went through because they
they tell their story in it it hangs
together it's a consistent story and she
says it grows to a thing of great
consistency so this is why I believe I
am a person and was that little boy
Julian many years ago and I think
actually the experience of you of me
seeing my hands moving and you seeing
them is because actually in your brain
all at once are quite a lot of images of
my hand and somehow rather when the
brain the brain tells a story it
presents us with a narrative and I think
what is happening is that it has a whole
lot of pictures all at once and presents
them as as movement like that but it's
not it's really in a whole lot of
snapshots there and the most the last
book that Oliver Sacks wrote called the
river of consciousness he talks about
the insights that neuroscience is
developing and it does really seem to be
that the the brain processes information
and presents first of all several
snapshots and then we see them as as as
movement so I don't think there is
movement out in the world it's something
that the brain it's a narrative that
some source comes to us through this at
a miracle of consciousness how that
nobody knows how consciousness works
anybody who says they do that that's
just nonsense to pretend that you know
that so I would say the only evidence
for the past and that there is something
that we really could call the past is
the consistency of our records
consistency of our memory and the fact
that we actually see movement I think
that's all it is you as I move my hand
like that you see my hands both there
and there and you see the movement but I
suspect that's that's a narrative that
the brain is presenting so that's that's
my explanation of why time itself is an
illusion and even motion is an illusion
but the fact that I can put my hands
like this in different positions that
not an illusion that's real so do we
have to have sort of trust in our own
memory or the consistency of our own
memory to feel like the past is real or
going or is that just an illusion that
do we have to give up I would say that's
the ultimate tragedy in life when your
brain has deteriorated I know this very
acutely because my poor wife developed
Alzheimer's over a very long period and
as she died just under two years ago so
I mean three years ago look how I'm
getting that wrong and that's that's the
saddest thing but she still was getting
some sense of her identity until tilted
til the end
but but that that's when the connections
in the brain no longer hold together as
they fall apart things fall apart within
the brain and of course that is that is
a sad end of life and and I'm at my age
I'm beginning to struggle with people's
names and things like that but I'm still
at least can talk about I remember a
line or two from Shakespeare's Midsummer
Night's Dream so how's it for you
personally your own theory of time
affected how you sort of experience like
feelings of sort of like regret which
may people like a consigned to the past
or hopes for the future well there's
plenty of things that I regret about the
past and some of the more stupid and
unpleasant things they do they make me
wince when I recall them but I think
that's actually as something to stop me
doing it again I think that's probably a
healthy thing but the main thing I have
from this is enjoy the moment carpe diem
make the most of every moment of your
life as best you can
so that's sort of the philosophy I've
developed and I put this in the epilogue
of the book that I wrote about this
called the end of time which came out
it's nearly twenty years ago it was
published so that's there you see I'm
using conventional terms but I could put
that all in my language of time capsules
and shapes of the universe and so on in
terms of the ramifications for physics
does this have a influence in quantum
physics and the gap between classical
and quantum physics it might I'm very
cautious about saying that we're onto
the right track at the moment actually
I'm with my three collaborators that we
think we're making real progress in just
within classical physics understanding
why the past is so different from the
present and the future because this is
the great mystery of the growth of
entropy which came with the discovery of
the laws of thermodynamics in a in the
1850s so all the known laws of nature
work equally well in the two directions
of time then why are all the processes
we observe in the universe all going in
the same direction we are all getting
older in the same direction you just
like me and all the stars are we never
meet anyone getting younger where is
this colossal asymmetry in time come
from if it's not in the fundamental laws
so seven years ago to make a concession
to time I an idea occurred to me which
actually I happen to know about a rather
important result in discovered in
Newton's theory of gravity in 1772 this
led me to the idea that the Big Bang so
if we pretend there is a timeline of the
universe which by which I mean just each
individual now what it's like like the
sills the moon we suppose you have a
long infinite timeline of the
universe and I would say that the Big
Bang is if you like in the middle and we
are on one side and our time is going
that way and then there's another
universe or the other half of the whole
timeline where time is going that way
now people who were on that side would
find that time is going forward in
exactly the same way as we find it on
this side it's all very chaotic at the
Big Bang there's no structure there so
we can't see through the Big Bang to the
other side and they can't see through to
us but that restores the overall
symmetry so the overall symmetry of the
whole universe reflects the underlying
law which is symmetric in both ways but
on the two sides the direction of
experienced time is opposite so that's
quite a simple neat thing so I call this
the Janice point or Janus point that the
Big Bang are of course after the Roman
god who looks in two opposite directions
of time at once and I'm writing a book
about this with the title is the Janus
point and a new theory of times arrows
and the Big Bang I hope I will get it
finished I'm working away ah fairly
recently had my 82nd birthday so I
better get it finished
I'm constant now fairly recently back in
February actually but it's a nice simple
idea and several quite interesting
things fit into this idea quite nicely
so and what is the main the main
challenges with this what what do you
see
or foresee is the main challenges that
you'll have to tackle and well first of
all first of all to show that this is
this model is based on Newton's theory
of gravity and quite a big challenge is
to show that it will also work with
Einstein's theory of gravity
now we've made it my collaborators made
a first step in that and they've showed
that in some senses there are conditions
in which you can go through the Big Bang
in general relativity and not only in
the the comparable such
in Newton's theory then there would be
more detailed work to be done but the
real challenge would be to make this
quantum mechanical to unify quantum
mechanics with this and we've got ideas
about this but people have been trying
for 6070 years to unify corner mechanics
with Einstein's theory of gravity and
they to be frankly haven't got terribly
far or despite them the claims that made
them like might like to make so that's
it there but one thing we do think is
that we concentrate on what we say the
shape of the universe in any instant so
if you have a triangle it has a shape
and a size but I think you'll agree that
the shape is much more important than
the size because if I hold up a an
equilateral triangle in front of your
eyes and move it backwards and forwards
the shape doesn't change but the size
does so you would say there's a question
mark over the size whether it's
fundamental now if you can if that
triangle is the whole universe you'd
need a ruler outside that triangle to
measure its size but if the universe is
everything that doesn't make sense so
we've developed something we call shape
dynamics to describe the whole universe
and we think that it might be possible
in that framework to unify quantum
mechanics with gravity with Einstein's
theory of gravity because it's taking
away something that shouldn't be there
and in fact all of the so far really all
of the existing approaches to quantum
gravity in some way or other are
bringing in an external scale which I
don't think should be there or at least
as a there's a question mark over it and
possibly a big one so that's our hope
but it's better to be getting on with in
the meanwhile for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you